this is a quick video about the basics
of working with numbers in JavaScript I
have it set up to log this number to the
console so we'll see it appear over here
and the numbers up here the number
equals 12 you can do all the standard
operations in JavaScript so I can do
plus 214 I can do minus 210 I can do
multiplication with the asterisk
yep 24 like you can do division with the
slash 6 and you can even divide and get
a decimal answer also there's the
modulus operator that gives you the
remainder so 12 modulus 7 we're going to
get a remainder of 5 it would really be
1 remainder 5 7 goes into 12 one time
with a remainder of 5 and you can do all
of these operations with decimals so I
can do 7.3 we can multiply by decimals
and you can divide with decimals and one
thing to notice is that all numbers are
eventually rounded off so it's not going
to go on forever
so that could affect accuracy in some
programs ok if you just want to add 1 to
a number you can do plus plus at the end
that is going to increment the number 1
so it started at 12 and now we're at 13
and you can also put minus minus to
decrement the number it's going to now
go down 1 a lot of times in programming
you want to do something like this
number equals number plus 5 and there's
a quick way to do that you can do it
like this plus equals so whenever you
see this number plus equals 5x
number equals number plus five you can
also do that with multiplication that
number equals number times 561 the
number is 12 you can do with division
you can do it with subtraction and then
I just want to show you one last thing
with the numbers plus plus you can see
that it's going to show 12 but if we do
console dot log number again so it's
going to consulate love the number then
it's going to increment after it logs it
so then when you log it again it's 13
however if I take this plus plus and put
that at the beginning of the the number
let me clear the console and run that
again it's going to increment the number
and then log the number so if you have
the plus plus or the minus minus before
the number it does that before doing
what it was just about to do with the
number which was logging it but if you
put the plus + or minus - after the
number first it does what it was going
to do which is logging it and then
increments or decrements the number well
those are numbers thanks for watching my
name is beau Carnes don't forget to
subscribe and remember use your code for
good